[Music]
wisdom
what's on your mind may do do we have
this mission as long as we stick
together we'll be fine if you go into
Shaw now would be a good time attention
this is your captain speaking we are on
final approach to Paris
that's our Jew you may now know all your
electronic devices where there is mostly
cloudy with a hundred percent chances
null sector invasions
[Music]
Winston clear is a spot to land we'll be
right behind you
why small sector attacking now I don't
know me but the people down there need
help then right now we're all they've
got
[Music]
[Music]
our officer we are here to help cpr
Sasha
[Applause]
good work
[Music]
[Applause]
take cover
[Music]
she needs help we can't stay here
tracer get everyone out of here I'll
hope for mine but you said to stick
together
don't worry I'll be right behind you
you'd better be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's get you back in the fight
[Music]
how are we going to stop this thing
me you backtrack
thank God
ready
[Music]
[Music]
victory is ours my friends hi Lena
Brigitta oh my gosh you've grown Oh
everyone this is me hi everyone I still
meet you Monsieur does this mean
overwatch is back
yes yes we are
[Music]
we're being overrun no sector is
everywhere
all of its long as I can what are you
doing here it's happening again
Harris was just the beginning this is a
mobile emission so watch it Jordan it's
beautiful it's the killer robot
look up there that's the Cabana shirt
then we know what we have to do
you're with me we're getting aboard that
ship
I knew you would return one day he has
been too long
faster
I can't do this who's made your choice
nobody was stop us
trouble is cropping up all over the
world it's not just in the center a lot
of lives are riding on what we do next
will you have to fight one city at a
time
[Music]
let's read them Brigitta
that's teamwork
right
[Music]
strike
our worthlessness
direction or until depletion things
[Music]
sojourn here
you
you